Leah, you just seem like you're like seething with rage and I
wish you would just say [laughter] what >> I'm finding
a through line. I'm building evidence. I'm trying to have a conversation
without him and you're like you're getting you're getting upset
with Stop talking, Max. Don't talk to me anymore for the rest
of the night. You're on timeout. >> Maybe. I thought I
could fix him. >> I think we could fix her. >> Destiny
broke me. My career died. My girlfriend left me and I went bald.
>> Other than that, things are going well.
Okay. So, what happened is Connor and Desessie had their crash
out. Conor said, "You're age playing with a groper's wife." And
they had this whole fight and all this, right? Connor, you come
to find out that the guy, the devil guy, the thing he told Connor
was that this woman, his his wife, his ex-wife, whatever, was
doing some sort of age play where they she involved the right.
They were stepparents like doing something to the
Connor asked the wife about it and the wife said, "No, the husband's
just husband's just making it up because he like wants to win
in a breakup or he's mad and all of this and he's making it up."
So Connor went on his merry way like told Destiny you shouldn't
engage with these kinds of people anymore. They obviously have
some problems and it's really bad, right? It seems like the allegation
has come out that now Destiny got pictures of this guy's too,
which is crazy. back in well I I assume November before. All
right.
But come to like this month, Connor realizes that Destiny is
still texting this woman, the woman who he thought was just doing
age play with him, some sort of babysitter, right? And then Connor
finds out that this woman wrote into Mr. Girl
and discussed like explicitly not not just age play, not just
babysitter stuff, but fantasizing about being the stepparents
of each other's and involving the in the role play. Okay.
And that changed Connor<unk>'s mind basically immediately
once he found out that that was the allegation, that the allegation
was true and that Destiny had continued to engage with this woman
after Connor had called him out for it. And so that's like the
quick rundown of why Connor was so upset and why he felt the
need to go public with a bunch of this stuff. >> Hello,
Connor. Welcome. >> Let's go. >> Hi, Lav. How are
you? >> I'm You know what? I'm doing so well. >> This
is what we're looking for. >> All right. Well, where where
do you want to start?
Well, let's let's start with the predator thing. I'm I'm interested
because you said that you still would not call him a predator
and that confuses me because then that makes me question why
you brought anything up at
>> because so I think then as in now
when people bring up predator
uh I think of may maybe this is because I'm accepting the colloquial
term too much or whatever um but I think of someone who's stalking
in the bushes
you know
disabled people. Well, is is that not what you're saying he's
doing with the mentally ill women?
>> No, because I think the mentally ill women have some
agency. >> Well, of course. What I mean isn't just Do you
not think that you could rap a girl who's drunk?
You can only
vegetable if you >> They have some agency.
>> Well, hold on. So, can you rap yourself
>> every day? I They're calling me the most alive. Can
we put the [laughter] Can we put the memes aside for a second?
We are talking about something serious. >> We can. >> So,
for me, uh especially being in a former law enforcement background,
uh rape is often times going to be forcible. Of course, there's
going to be like drunk or incapacitated or people who don't have
the ability to consent, etc., etc., etc. And so, while I think
the women that I'm criticizing Steven for are mentally ill, I
don't think that they're so mentally ill that they are incapable
of giving consent in an adult context. They are adults. >> Okay.
Interesting. I think that that would call into a question that
what capable means in your definition of capable. But um I did
a quick Google search and predator is an individual who exploits
others in an abusive non-consensual manner, often using power,
coercion, or grooming behaviors. And now I'm not an expert on
the
but it does seem
as though even in your definition that is what is happening.
>> Well, yeah, but do you want to um do you want to call
Anna Voir and see if she thinks that Steven is a predator
>> or Brit? >> I I think >> or Sherry might
have a different Sherry might have a different answer. >> Get
them all on Get him in here. >> Okay. Well, I mean I I
would, but a lot of them um a lot of them want to move on the
regardless of whether >> part of that is because of what's
happening to you, which is also an exercise of power. Correct.
>> Uh sure. But >> part of why Cherry doesn't want
to be involved in this at all is exactly that.
>> Sure. But what I would say is that >> at some
at some point somebody just have, you know, and I I'm I'm sure
you guys might even identify with the sentiment. At some point
you just have to have the balls to say you, right? I mean, that's
exactly what I did, and I got I got lambasted for that, too.
so so here here's uh here's something that I was talking to somebody
else about earlier tonight. One of the funny things that I think
happens is Steven seems to attract and interact with and find
most interesting
mentally ill people who have uh poor reputations
both online or in real life, right? And yet what makes them attractive
in the first place is their poor reputations, their weird insights,
their mental illness, but then their mental illness and poor
reputations is what's used to dismiss >> So Conor, what
we would call that is a predator. You're absolutely right. Yes,
that is. >> No, I don't. Okay. Once again, when I I'm saying
colloquially,
I really would like to move past the memes, but like [laughter]
I'm not >> I'm not being I'm not going to be calling Steven
predator and invoking ideas of a creepy man lurking in the bushes
in order to drug and women. That is not what I'm accusing him
of. And by the way, I think part of the problem here is hyperbole.
I think part of the problem is whenever somebody uh does criticize
Stephen, they'll engage in hyperbole. Um or they'll they'll stake
out the strongest claim. And the strongest claim, I'm even guilty
of this. Um, stake out the strongest claim that is insufficiently
evidenced when the truth is that there are claims that are infinitely
more strong that are still damning.
like being a >> well so for instance the um I think that
based off of the evidence that I presented of the husband saying
what he said the wife saying what he said Destiny admitting to
age play but minimizing it he at minimum engaged in age play
I think there's an above 70 with a mentally ill woman while being
sued for misconduct
>> now I think there's an above 70%. So, so we already
got age play. That That's like dumb. >> Wait, can I can
I can I ask something? >> Please go ahead. >> I'll
allow >> I would like to separate criticisms of poor strategy
like you're doing this while you're being sued for misconduct
from moral criticisms.
Cuz I it feels like when we blend those together,
like you're doing something immoral
and you're doing something stupid,
then it has a tendency to
I guess kind of soften the moral
>> B, I guess I could try. But you do understand that like
in in the process of mourning what is a six-year online relationship
and probably a two-year friendship. I myself waffle between
what I think is like malevolent and what I think is recklessness.
>> Right. So So >> well, but I'm not I'm not Wait.
Malevolent and reckless
are on a spectrum from intentional to unintentional. But I'm
talking about a criticism
that is of the impact. This is wrong to do because of how it
impacts others versus poor strategy because of how it impacts
you. It's not immoral to blow to >> himself. Like it's
not immoral to screw up his own lawsuit. It's just stupid. But
it's not like it's not wrong. >> Well, well, hold on. So
m maybe I can bridge the gap here and I promise you I'm not trying
to be evasive or not do what you're asking me to do. I promise
you I'm trying to fulfill what you're asking me to do. Okay.
>> Um but I think that
at some point it is incumbent upon Steven where recklessness
is no longer an excuse.
So for instance um if we go through the Mr. report and we look
at a decade of broken relationships
and then we know that 2022 is the peak of the drama where you
guys are in orbit and then you get driven out of orbit. Then
we allegedly have a calming period after 2022, but then this
all reexlodes in 2024.
Well, then at that point, he really should have stopped reckless
behavior in 2022 when he was kicking you two out of orbit. But
the uh Brit situation in my opinion just shows that he hasn't
learned that his
his unintentional danger to other people um is bad and harmful
and it hurts other people. And so at that point the recklessness
I think does become a moral calculation where even if he claims
recklessness at this point he should know like like long overdue
for him to know that his recklessness damages other people.
>> I see what you're saying but I'm a little concerned
for him.
So basically you're saying like he's drunk driving.
>> He's drunk driving and he's consistently hitting Yeah.
Okay. >> And that is people's like emotional
Yes, that's fair. >> And by the way, we can make we can
stake out um if you want to work your way up to like I think
I think even his own fans
would admit recklessness.
>> If you want to work your way up to Malefics, I'm fine.
>> No, no, no. I'm not. That's not what I'm trying to do.
I'm saying that the DG
language
around how to evaluate Destiny's character and behavior
is always focused on always bringing it back to strategy. So
you can never say he did something morally wrong. That gets turned
into and he did it while he was being sued. like what an idiot
implying that what he should be doing is
I I don't know strategizing better and doing whatever is best
for him at all times and it kind of blends together
the moral criticism of like he is doing harm to people whether
it's intentional or not whether it's like organized or compulsive
like who knows what he's really thinking
versus
uh is he just being dumb and shooting himself in the foot >> if
if I do that during this convers ation. Please forgive me. It
will be >> I'm Yeah, I'm It's not I'm just I I just want
to point it out because I'm worried that if those get mixed together,
then we can't really talk about like harm.
Um Steven's history is very well documented. It's at minimum
well documented as chaotic. Um it's at maximum uh documented
as like toxic. And I think you would use the word predatory.
I think you >> abusive or predatory. >> Yeah. Okay.
Abusive. There you go. Um so depending on how you perceive these
uh incidents over the past decade, decade and a half. Um you're
going to have somewhere on the spectrum you're going to have
dysfunctional but funny or you're going to have predatory or
abusive depending on how you perceive the scenarios. So, in my
opinion,
um, Britt, I'm just going to talk to about people openly because
I I think when we hem and haw around the scenario, I think it
gets more silly. Britt is an adult. Britt was smart enough in
order to get into the military. Britt has trauma. Britt is seen
a therapist about her trauma. Britt has family who care about
her. In what world would it be recommended to that woman to engage
in a longd distanceance communication uh relationship with a
man while married
and also de dealing with like post-traumatic stress disorder
and military related trauma? >> The answer is never. The
answer is never. No sane person would ever recommend this for
Brit. And yet she chose to do it because she is a person with
agency. But wait, two things. One,
>> why are we talking about that?
>> Because uh why' you say that? Lav is asking why I'm
why I'm still insisting on blaming Destiny's victims by acknowledging
that they are, you know, uh that if anybody past this point engages
with Steven, then they should know what they're getting into.
>> But but they should know what they're getting into.
They don't is the problem is he keeps putting himself in situations
where these women >> Why don't they >> because
because they're not full agents because even you say they're
extremely mentally ill, Connor. >> Yeah. I I think it feels
like you're saying they're mentally >> I don't think mental
illness is an excuse to like lose all agency. >> Mental
ill. That's literally what keeps people from buying guns. It
keeps [laughter] people >> wait if it's if it Why mention
that they're mentally ill at all if it doesn't impact their agency,
>> It does impact their agency. It just doesn't eliminate
it. >> Nobody's saying it's eliminated. >> But to
the extent to the extent that it impacts it, isn't that the same
extent that it's
morally wrong to
with them? >> Which is why I asked you earlier like >> Well,
funnily enough, we uh >> a bunch of different things. >> Sorry.
Go ahead. I was I was this is why I asked you earlier. There's
a bunch of different things. Can you only someone in a coma?
Obviously not. There's different levels of agency. There's different
types of rape. There's different types of abuse. There's different
types of agency. Obviously, these women have very little >> I
I would think based off
any current evaluation of the law and the way in which capacity
and agency are evaluated. I do not think that Steven is guilty.
>> Okay. At least I don't have any evidence. I wouldn't
call rape either, but I'm talking about >> my I think that
we should get away from trying to argue about what terms like
rape and predator mean.
>> But I I think that you're invoking their mental illness
when you want to criticize him for being
and then ignoring their mental illness when evaluating the morality
of his
>> No, I'm not ignoring it.
You you could articulate how I'm ignoring it. I don't think I'm
ignoring it at all.
>> Well, I I think it's part of the reason why I was willing
to burn the bridge with Stephen this past week
>> is because I found So, I found out No, hold on. Let
Let me articulate this and you can tell me where I'm at. So,
I think in November, well, actually, let's back up just a little
bit. Please indulge me or rant.
In February of 2025 or January of 2025, Steven lost 99% of his
orbiters and friends, right? because of the Pixie
And then everybody's been slowly drifting back in. Well, I never
left, right? But I was not leaving because I was hoping against
hope that this was going to be such an extreme situation that
he would wake up. And in November, I find out that he's and my
my logs are out there. If you want to read the logs, we could
even read them out out think uh out loud. But November, I find
out that he's a mentally ill woman. An obviously mentally ill
woman. I'm able to identify her mental illness within
five minutes of talking to her. I know that she's severely mentally
ill, >> And so I say, "Hey, Stephen, the husband of a mentally
ill woman is telling me that you engage in age play with a mentally
ill woman. >> How did you come into contact?" Hold on.
Let me finish, please. Let me finish, >> Right. I say,
"I like you for all of the blow reasons,
but you are destroying yourself and you're making it impossible
to be your friend." Okay, that's where I feel like you were alluding
to the fact that I'm uh I'm trying to excuse Steven's behavior.
>> Well, now with Hold on, please. Please. I promise you.
But you're saying something that I promise you I'm almost done.
I >> can you not say what I'm what I mean in the middle
of the thing I'm not allowed to respond to? >> Sure. I
will focus on what I'm saying, but I would like the opportunity
to finish what I'm saying. And I promise I am almost done.
>> When I found out that they were still communicating
in this past week, that is inexcusable to me. It's inexcusable
because I gave him a shot across the bow in November. It's inexcusable
because of the allegations that he has already been under in
reference to this situation. It's inexcusable because of what's
hap uh happened with the Pixie case. It's inexcusable
because of his claimed uh personal and professional ambitions.
It is inexcusable for him to be engaged
actively with this woman at this time.
>> Okay. My assessment of what you said is that it does
feel like there is a
or eclipsing of the moral question with
is Destiny harming himself and his own career question. Is is
it reckless or stupid? Feels like
you're not saying like, "Hey, you can't do this because it's
wrong to do to other people."
>> that's interesting. I'm in I'm in the room with the
man who says you can fantasize about whatever you want. >> Well,
well, yeah, but I don't think that I don't think that Max would
ever say involve the
>> I didn't say you can wait a second.
I didn't say you can do whatever you want. Okay. Those are different.
>> Well, hold on. Hold on, hun. May maybe you could parse
this apart for >> Well, also maybe I'm a hypocrite and
I'm stupid. Like that that doesn't change what doesn't change
my point. My point is that >> Well, you Yeah, sorry. I'll
try to listen to your point separate from the statement I just
made. But I do think that you're the guy who said that is interesting.
But sorry, >> we we can I'm happy to be pressed on that.
I just it just feels like you're speaking some of the DG
language where we can't just say
uh he's taking advant like you went to call him a predator and
say he's women or whatever. You could say he's
taking advantage of people. There is a power differential. There
are things that are unethical about what he's doing separate
from how they may harm his own career. But it feels like you
invoke
mental illness
only when you're talking about a vulnerability to him and how
it might harm him. But then when we try but then when when Leah
says, "But that same mental illness also poses a danger to the
women you're saying are mentally ill." And you're like, "No,
they can consent. They're adults. They got into the military.
They whatever."
>> Maybe he's the BPD girl.
>> I I think that's fair. I think that's fair, but I don't
think it's
a a really a response to the idea that it's not fair to the to
out this. >> You're right. It's not fair to the to out
this. However, my frustration with this is that often times,
and I'm not saying you're doing this, but other people are doing
this. Some people will hide behind the effects to potential victims
in order to allow somebody to continue in bad behavior.
And that's not something that I'm gonna permit. What? Like that
that's not that's not part of my calculation. So for instance,
like
>> the whole thing's gonna come down. >> Is Connor
screaming >> domestic violence battery scenario? >> Well,
if you arrest the perpetrator of domestic violence battery, like
Lab's >> there's no way Lab's the only one. >> Well,
maybe he's going to be angry that Lav reported him for domestic
violence battery. [gasps] And then when he comes
>> he's going to beat the out of her even harder in a context.
It's just going to be straight beating. there's gonna be no >> if
there's a woman who deserves it.
>> right. And so
that calculation of, oh well, if we expose this information or
if we take action against this person, they're going to behave
even worse. >> That's not an incentive structure that I
can respond to. >> Also, I feel like while you didn't intend
that, you were actually trying to >> probably thread the
ego involved here in a way responsible of action. That's
just not a logic structure that I'm responding responsive to.
>> Well, I just think that the whole the only harm that's
going to come from the alleged role playing is if they find out
about it and then by broadcasting it, you're the one who's telling
them. >> Okay. Then if that's true, the uh number one,
the people who engaged in the role playing are the people who
are responsible for that, not me. Number two, if the exposure
of this alleged scenario deters other people from engaging in
this behavior, then there could be people who basically say,
"Oh, I was thinking about um I was listening to this Mr. Girl
thing. He was saying I could fantasize about whatever I want."
And uh and yet somebody is being publicly punished for enacting
their own fantasies uh because they were antisocial.
I'm not going to engage in my antisocial fantasies. I would rather
have that impact on the world, truth be >> Okay. So you're
actually So the problem is it that you think that he's done anything
morally wrong then but you just think that he's stupid.
>> No, I think that jerk. Okay. The
from this is what this is what gives me
>> I don't think Jesse would ever do something like that.
>> Yeah. It's not it's not like there's I don't think any
proof, but obviously it's something. >> Let's move a little
bit forward, okay? because I've been accused of not substantiating
uh my claims with sufficient evidence. Um I think there's
>> Sure. Um there's an 80 to 90% chance in my opinion that
they engaged in the
fantasy and the step woman step
her fantasy. I think is 80% enough for you to 80 80 to 90 is
enough for you to
>> broadcast it feel like you want
>> What are you planning on doing now? You're out of the
orbit. You've said that you're out of the orbit.
>> What? Leah, what are you what are you >> Well,
I'm interested on I'm interested. I'm asking questions that give
me like you're like grilling him. >> I'm not grilling him.
>> It's fine. I don't care. >> You are grilling him.
But why? >> I'm not grilling him. I'm asking questions.
I want to know where he is psychologically without asking like
how are you psychologically? I'm trying to get the real answer
instead of like >> you know where he is.
>> We've we've both been through this exact thing and we
did and said all the exact same things that he's saying and doing
>> Well, I don't know if it's the exact same but yes. >> I
mean [laughter] I mean bait pretty >> Don't worry don't
worry Conor that's also a part of the process. >> Not like
hey are you on like t >> Don't worry Conor that that revulsion
at being compared to Mr. Girl that's also a part of the process.
So, so what I would say is, [laughter] um, I'm out of orbit.
Um, I'm still going to cover his content. I analogized it to
[laughter] R. Kelly. Do you guys remember the song
>> Do I remember it? Of course.
>> Okay. Well, Ignition is so good. I don't care that R.
Kelly on 30year-olds.
So
Steven is an interesting enough internet debater that even if
he roleplayed I I won't even be specific. Even if he did did
some nasty freak, I'll cover his debates when they're interesting.
I'll agree with him when I think it's correct. I'll disagree
with him when I think it's correct. I'll criticize him. >> I'm
trying to find a through line. And this is why I asked you several
questions even though Max is >> literally answering your
question. But go ahead, Leah. >> No, I I I found a line.
Leah, you just seem like you're like seething with rage and I
wish you would just say [laughter] >> I'm finding a through
line. I'm building evidence. I'm trying to have a conversation
without him and you're like you're getting you're getting upset
with Stop talking, Max. Don't talk to me anymore for the rest
of the night. You're on timeout. You're on 0%.
I'm just kidding. [laughter] >> Jeez, you guys are sensitive.
>> You're not on 0%. Um, >> hang out with
Don't call it the podcast ever. Call it the most sensitive Scott
podcast.
It's two control freaks in a room. Um, but no, I'm I'm I'm trying
to understand through all of this because you're you're saying
and now maybe I am actually grilling you because I >> think
that this is interesting because you somehow as
antisocial behavior
while you say the most antisocial things I've heard out of anyone.
Even Steven, you say more you say more antisocial things than
even Steven would say, I think. at least
>> like like how you don't like how you don't care about
um if R. Kelly onyold girls or you don't care about the victims.
You don't care about women. You don't think that you think that
victims are saying ignition is bad. You think victims have agency.
You think all these things like or you think that they have more
agency than even is allotted. No, we're not even talking about
that. Connor, let me finish. You're saying all these things that
are like expressly antisocial. If we're even talking about like
if you fall under like the philosophical school of thought which
I think is like close to something like Emanuel Kant about like
rules and about like uh uh of of who we should be who we ought
to be your falling flat of even your own
what I'm what I'm thinking is like okay are or would Destiny's
actions be per permissive if he was like yeah I'm up I'm supered
up it is what it is I can't stop doing this I'm up like would
that if he was like, "Yeah, I have a problem. I need to help."
Max does this to >> Would that change anything for you?
Could he still keep messing up and keep messing up? >> If
he was actually on the Hold on. This would be more explained
by Christianity than Kant.
over this on Oh my god, Leah. Please, >> please allow me
to expand on the idea. >> Okay. I was in the church for
18 years,
>> Okay. I was taught that
and murderers and eveners
are capable of achieving atonement and forgiveness, right? Through
God, maybe not on the material plane, but through >> In
order when you say, "Oh, well, if Steven recognized that he was
up, would that instantaneously change my calculation of the consequences
that he should suffer?"
>> He would still have to go through the process I just
articulated.
>> He needs your help.
>> I agree. I agree. >> I truly think his time would
be better served by speaking with a therapist about his trauma,
trying to recognize the way in which he's sociopathic,
trying to realize that being pro-social
um benefits him, not just other people, because sociopaths are
very difficult to reform. Yeah. >> I I don't think this
>> seems like Max has something to say. So, I'm sorry for
telling you to shut the up, Max. If you got something to say,
say it. >> I think if you're going to make a joke, it should
be funny.
I'm not I'm not funny because I'm not a >> That was funny.
There we go. [laughter] Two. I don't want to do a
What
was Steven needs to get help
>> What are you talking about? What are you
>> What is your What are your thoughts on it then? What
are What is your full formed thought on all of this now? >> On
what's happening? >> We'll do it. We'll do it.
I don't know if Connor has fully fledged his out. We'll give
him space to do it. I want to hear yours. I'll do mine as well,
but let's hear yours. >> I think that Connor is where we
were and where every orbiter
streamer member of the DGG cult finds themselves eventually
where something clicks. You realize you're a part of something
that you should not be part of.
your
identity is destabilized cuz you don't know what you've been
doing and you don't know who your friends are or what's happening
and you think that if you explain yourself it'll you can make
it click for other people. You think, "Well, I saw this thing
and it clicked for me and >> and you >> it'll click
for some other people. It'll click for some people." You you'll
peel off a layer of the onion,
>> but the like you said, you bump into 50, you're the
problem. >> At this point, the list of
villains in the mythology of this cult is so long that they're
they do really have an endless ability to metabolize anything.
And you and you I'm sure you've I know you've heard the counter
narratives. They don't make sense at all. Like, oh, she was lying
to make him look bad and we now have proof of this. That the
standard of what proof is completely changes. But Hutch was like,
I don't see I don't even see how this is perverted. He just completely
blanked out what was being told to him.
>> It's very Sorry. That was actually that was actually
really funny to me where we're literally talking about >> it's
weird >> off to
>> and his analogy slash joke was well because of neuroplasticity
if you do doggy style then eventually you're going to want to
dogs and I was >> which in my experience is true >> way
to miss the point completely that
I'm like the only one who laughed I feel I I feel I I'm truly
sometimes blown
>> by what passes for content with some >> I think
there's a lot of double speak going on here about if the the
women are mentally ill or they're not mentally ill or Connor
was brainwashed. >> But but you get mad at me when I prod
>> the double speak. So Connor's
uh brainwashed lemming who just goes from organization to organization
with no sense of purpose like the army or his own family or the
church or whatever the you're implying
or Connor is an adult and it was just banter and it's always
been like this and the Twitch politics is just fun and we just
throw elbows sometimes.
And I think all of this
introduces
moral confusion about the cult figure head >> It might.
>> But we but and that's why I thought >> all of
it all of it all of it serves to introduce confusion about what
happened. >> This is why I thought it was useful to tell
to each of us tell what we think is going on because I think
I have a very different opinion than you do.
>> Here here's a here's a potentially productive point.
So, Max, I agree with you that some DJers, particularly the people
who are in my replies on Twitter, can 100% exhibit uh cultlike
behavior. I I think that's just like descriptively true. Um,
however, I do think that there's probably
subops
of DGG who interact with uh different levels of ferveny and also
have different levels of dedication to Steven. And I think that
the cultists are actually like a subcategory of the population.
They're not necessarily the entire thing. And so if it sounds
like I'm not like jumping on board like, "Oh >> I don't
know what the percentages are or whatever." It's partially because
I actually delineate like leveling
to a disagreement that you guys have with me about how much it's
a cult. I'm pointing to internal contradictions about the way
you are talking about it where you yourselves cannot decide how
much of a cult it is, how much his behavior is immoral,
how much agency you yourselves have.
>> You don't know the most or is he just a guy you like
arguing with who sometimes does irresponsible stuff with mentally
ill women? >> These are not compatible views. You you >> Well,
the truth is probably in the middle though, right?
>> I don't know where the truth >> Not for the most
black and white thinker you've ever met in your life. No, >> I
don't know where the truth is. And I'm
coherence
is not black and white thinking. I'm saying that the way you
guys are talking about this whole situation is internally contradictory.
You don't seem to have a position. >> Can you give us >> I
have a position. I have a very strong >> Okay. Well, okay.
Yeah. go ahead with it. But I I was going to try to identify
a sole variable and then try to resolve the incoherence. But
uh Leah, if you want to articulate your position, please go ahead.
>> I I think that uh that the community can act like a
cult at certain points, but I also think that Destiny, more so
than anything, is in a very codependent relationship with his
internet fame. And I think that that makes him uh impulsive and
it makes him ego-driven
and it makes him and it makes him an addict. And I think that
because of that he's completely out of control. I think that
some of the things he does on purpose I think some of the things
he doesn't do on purpose. >> This is an example of what
I'm talking about. You're asked to analyze is this organization
structurally a cult? And within 20 words you're saying Steven
is egovenriven.
This is not related to the question that is put before you and
it's the question. >> I said I said that I said I said
it >> Can you identify the question? What's the question?
What's the question you want us to contend? >> Max is actually
seething now. Max is going to punch a wall. >> I'm not
even really asking a question. The question is is DG a cult.
But my critique is you slide between
yes it is and no it's not. Yes, I'm a victim. No, no, I'm not
a direct. I don't have agency. The mentally women ill women have
agency. the mentally ill women are victims. They don't have agency.
Destiny's a predator. No, actually, he's just not that bad. And
then not even being able to stay on topic of like, is it structure?
And then we're talking about the internal psychology. No, I think
he needs help. You're all over the place. And the being all over
the place at a time, the being all over the place and not being
able to follow a single conversational thread is a feature of
the cult. not being able to clearly about what we're talking
about is the nature of conversation. But but hold on, you it
Well, Max, if you wanted to resolve the incoherence,
then what you could have done is you could have set expectations
that this is effectively going to be an interview run by you.
That's not what happened. Leah basically invited me and said,
"Hey, let's let's all chat together and catch up." And I >> "That
sounds not a response to any you were like, tell me the question."
The question is, is DG a cult? And you're like, okay, look, >> you
should have you should have prepped me for this conversation.
You didn't. Now we're launching into a meta critique of how I
introduced the conversation.
>> Please stop. Please. >> Do you think DG is a cult?
>> I think there's a subcomponent of DGG that is a cult.
Are you in it? >> I think the bigger question is, can some
can something accidentally be a cult?
>> Is it a conscious cult? >> Is it a conscious cult?
Is it a cult? I think conversation >> but but don't don't
muddy the water. Max wants to drive >> unironically become
violent. >> Well, it is because it's distracting from the
pause to bear down on my >> Listening. Okay. >> No,
I was not a part of the cult element of DGG. >> Okay. In
your view, >> you were part of the cool community part
which has shrunk since 2021 to 2022
as Destiny is revealed to be more and more of a degenerate. in
your words.
>> And the people who don't like antisocial behavior peel
off making so the core
cult follow maybe you don't even think of them as the core. The
cult element becomes a larger percentage of DGG.
>> That's wildly insightful. Yes. Keep >> Re recursively
emboldening Destiny to do more and more degenerate things because
he has less and less to lose. And
finally he has crossed a line for you where you
through some combination of it just being too much and you maybe
not being able to
because you care about him and be you know also because you're
invested some sunk cost. >> Okay. Can I >> you you
left? >> No he's cooking. Let him cook. >> He's not.
And now as a result of leaving
the non-cult part of DGG, the cult that is left behind is attacking
you.
>> You you summarized it beautifully.
Now, I think you're talking about how I think I think Max tries
to make this about how Destiny is like the overlord of this.
I think Destiny is a victim inside of it. Uh, an occult can form
on
>> How it forms on accident is unchecked charisma, which
is things that we're literally talking about. Like I'm I'm looking
like a leader might genuinely believe in their own message and
possess a magnetic personality. Okay. Mission creep group centered
around a shared hobby, wellness, or business can become obsessive.
Creeping authoritarianism to solve administrative or interpersonal
problems. A group may centralize decision-m us versus them mentality.
An effort to build a tight-knit community. members may start
viewing the outside world as toxic, hostile or inferior. The
isolation creates an environment where the group's reality criticized
her earlier. That's why she's forgetting that like to be a content
creator, to be destiny is probably hell. >> He doesn't
look well. Like he doesn't look like he's having fun anymore.
He doesn't look like he's doing this on purpose. He's obviously
completely floundering. He's completely out of control. I mean,
it's not He's getting He's getting hate every single day. He's
obviously has to deal with things. Um, hold on. But I but I want
to uh show how what Mr. Girl just said, which I felt was insightful,
particularly the part where you recognize that as the quote unquote
chill part of DGG has less of an influence within the community,
the toxic element is emboldened. And then also the toxic element,
uh, since the cool people are already gone, the amount of people
who are willing to criticize, the amount of people who are willing
to do, I thought that was perfectly well articulated. Now to
show how what Leah said is not contradictory though. Um I feel
like Vosch, I feel like Lauren Southern, I feel like Destiny
and I feel like Nick Fentes
um have been trapped in what I call gilded cages. So effectively
they have attracted an audience that has a set of beliefs and
they've gone they've hundreds of thousands of views, maybe millions
of views, hundreds of thousands of dollars, sometimes millions
of dollars. They are materially well off. They have succeeded
in the world of content creation. But what has happened is because
they have rammed such a hardcore
principled ideological
uh frame like over and over and over again. if they try to leave
that frame in any way whatsoever, they effectively get like [__]
on by the community that they've created to get back in the box
and keep producing the content that their audience wants to hear.
And so for me, um, I look at Vosch, I I look at, uh, Stephen,
I look at, uh, Nick Fentes, and I'll admit I'm jealous of the
materialism, but what I'm not jealous of is the communities that
they've cultivated, because I feel like the communities that
they cultivated will never let them be free of their own um,
cult of personality
and what it's built around. >> What do you think, Max?
>> I'm just letting them think. >> Yeah, I think
I think you're right. I don't think it's contradictory. I think
as a nonsequittor to talk about
how Destiny feels again. It's just >> then where where
would you like to go next, Max? >> This is where I want
to go. I want to make the comment that
it feels like we can't talk about it's a cult without also talking
about oh but what Destiny's overwhelmed
or something like it just I just don't I don't think it's labusion.
I think there's a lot >> Leah and I still have sympathy
or him. >> I have sympathy for him. It just doesn't cloud
my I I don't think it clouds my thinking about whether it's a
cult. >> I don't think it clouds my Well, I'm in the middle.
I I still think it's a cult just accidentally. >> Why would
it matter? >> We're all different. We [laughter] would
matter how it views on this, I guess. >> What is the purpose
of Jews, five >> Yeah. I mean from from like a mental health
perspective like obviously I hope that Steven gets help genuinely.
I mean from from a someone who's a victim of >> I don't
know why we are talking about why are we talking I don't know
why we keep talking
>> yeah you're muddying the waters by basically trying
to make it Steven focused. I muddied the waters by making it
Steven focused by sweeping for him by blaming the women. How
is it not the
What do you how does it not >> Max and how it's it shouldn't
be Stephen Focus if we're talking about >> because it feels
sweepy.
>> It feels sweepy. At some point I'm going to just call
Max be like, "Hey, you want to come?" >> It's just like
not a response to the It's like just not a response to the last
thing that was said. It's just vomiting out random stuff so that
we're not talking about anything
and it just feels like that's that's DGG. It's like there's a
thing you're not allowed to talk about. >> Okay. There's
a thing you're not allowed to talk about. And the thing is
and and really
quantifying and accounting for the harm done by Destiny and DGG.
And instead of talking about that, we have to compare it to other
communities and other creators. We have to talk about his mental
health and how it's affecting him. We have to talk about how
intentional is it? And it's like I I can I quantify the specific
harm No, I want to clarify this I wanted >> I want to talk
about this situation. >> Yeah, if you want to.
>> So,
I can't help
but think
that when
Britt and
Devil first contacted me that when they told me that they were
military veterans dealing with mental health issues, I became
more protective of them. I conscious, subconscious,
I'm sure that on a like it was in there somewhere, right? >> And
so when I think of people who have been through the service,
I know how tough that can be. When I think about people who have
military related trauma, it's MST. Um they I I know what that's
like. I know what that's been like. I have friends who are like
that. Um, so I think I probably
while being repulsed by the allegations,
I was also more sympathetic to them as victims of of Steven's
misbehavior.
And so,
um, when I gave him, in my opinion, a shot across the bow in
November where I say, you know, I basically ran with the narrative
that you're talking about where I'm being sympathetic to his
perspective and I'm worried about his public reputation and blahy
blahy blah
I think that any sane person who wasn't self-destructive
would have heard that shot across the bow and been like, "Damn,
my friend for the past year who's kind of been like, you know,
maintained orbit, maintained his friendship, gone shooting with
me. He's kind of calling me out on my bad behavior and I'm putting
people at risk that he, you know, potentially cares about. Maybe
I should back the off and do the responsible thing." And so to
find out that he's still talking to Brit within the past, >> he's
obviously not any of those things. He's not the same person.
What happens to that is >> doesn't give a [__]
what happens to Devil. Doesn't give a [__] what happens
to Brit. >> And um what he's doing now in my opinion is
me exposing it. Brit is uh she waffles um between
and
endless devotion and love for Steven. She literally flip-flops
between the two depending on the day and the hour. It re So
love for Stephen, right? And so to me,
by exposing it, I'm increasing her chances of herself.
But guess what? That's not my sin to bear. That's his.
[laughter] He was mentally ill. He knew that she was mentally
ill within five minutes. He got a shot across the stop >> He
uh was sat on it for 6 months. He continued to communicate with
her. So
he is playing with the lives of other people and if they end
up themselves or god forbid
out about the entire situation because this was an ongoing situation
for months >> and what if he killed Brit? >> That
was another entirely possible variable to happen here. So to
see that my former friend didn't give a about whether or not
somebody else got killed or whether or not somebody committed,
I was done with it. It wasn't something that I was going to be
able to >> lab's not imagined the same way people
>> Not the same way Conor is. >> I can't defend it.
I can't sweep for it. I can't say it's okay. It's not okay. It's
not okay. >> Am I correct that you see this as a significant
escalation from his past behavior? Weirdly enough, I don't
because I think that Sherry and Anavoir
were similarly
uh manic people who could have uh messed around with >> Conor's
opinions are mental health on mental health are so [__]
crazy.
>> I could name three more. [laughter] >> Yeah, I
mean, if you want to name them, you can just ram the point home.
I'm thinking of Sherry and Anavoir. Who are you thinking of?
>> I'm thinking about like Baby Peach. I'm thinking about
uh the Pixie who said she was going to kill herself. Like I'm
thinking like there's obviously I mean there's obviously like
a there's a there's a >> No, Pixie. No, I I should I think
the reason I might have even preempted Sorry, real quick. Mind
>> leaving. I might have even preempted mentioning Pixie
because I know that the narrative is, oh well, she's just baiting.
Like I already know they're already going to dismiss it. But
hold on. with Sherry and Anavoir. I think they're undismissable
cases,
>> Vulnerable people >> who could be pushed past
the brink and yet what happens to them doesn't matter. >> I'm
asking
how you square not leaving before if you don't think this is
an escalation. >> Maybe I thought I could fix him. >> We
all think we could fix our boyfriends and husbands. >> WHY
DID HE SAY THAT? I >> does he not know how hard he's going
to get meme for saying that? >> I think that Steven has
been so routinely
betrayed
>> by people who suck up to him,
>> hang out with him, say he's the best thing since sliced
bread, >> take his money, take his,
take his that. >> And then when it's convenient, they
a knife jab a knife in his back and then they dip out. So, I
only found out like I knew about I knew about Brit saying that
they did age play, but it was like babysitter or something. That
was her story in November. Then the husband obviously alleged
what Britt wrote into your
calling show. No, she did alleged >> she like she liked
the stream. It was under her own Substack and her own Substack
was linked to her Discord.
So anyways,
>> point is Oh, and then she also admitted to it in direct
messages with Stephen that had been screenshotted and posted
to the internet
>> allegedly.
So So the point is that I only found out about Brit
allegedly
writing in that email to your show on
Saturday, Sunday, something like that. like after after the may
it might have been Saturday before I confronted Stephen or it
could have been after. I'd have to check the the logs. But the
point is that this has been an evolving process for the past
week. But what triggered this was Friday.
And the triggering point on Friday was not that Steven was a
self-destructive
freak. It's that he [snorts] thought that he could leverage our
relationship into the way that I controlled my community without
evidence.
>> That was the problem. >> And I basically like
uh I know this isn't the most exciting content on the >> Yeah,
my watch time was >> I actually wrote
reasonable ask highlighted in green, unreasonable ask in red.
Okay. And the reasonable ask was,
um, don't let snarkers into my community to end or into your
community to endlessly talk [__] about me. That's
a reasonable ask. I should not be permitting
random Twitch and YouTube political members to obsessively talk
about Steven. That's >> I don't I don't think that reasonable.
That's cult. >> Well, hold on. Hold on. Because I'll tell
you the implicit threat that I inferred from the scenario, which
is since these people are critical of me and they're not that
important to your community, your community is not going to be
mo made or broken off of these people, you should ban them in
order to keep associating with me. That was the implicit threat.
And so, not only did I write the implicit threat, but Mutton
called into the stream before Destiny called into the stream
later, and I said, "Hey, I'm kind of inferring this implicit
threat based off of what's being said right now. Am I getting
this right?" And he was like, "Yep,
that was it. We we are threatening to And obviously there there's
a huge uh clout cross-pollination
financial benefit to collaborating with Stephen, especially when
you're a small creator. Um, so as soon as Mutton confirmed the
implicit threat, I was like, "Okay, you you know that that that's
kind of my attitude because like
if we have a six-year
online debate relationship and we have a one to
IRL friendship, which really we've only hung out like a half
a dozen times, but obviously I cared about it. He said that he
cared about it.
And you think you can strongarm me into the way that I manage
my community? you that that means that you have no respect for
me whatsoever. You think that if you clap a couple of times,
I'll suck your you
um so that's the attitude I took on Friday and then everything
spiraled from there. So that's what I have to say. It's 12:35.
I'm 5 minutes past uh tea time. So, okay. Well, as noisy as this
conversation was,
I did have fun. I know that uh Max might not have wanted to have
fun in this conversation. No, he needed to be very serious. It's
a very serious matter.
>> It was it was interesting and fun to reconnect with
y'all. And as much as we disagree about a whole host of
I wish you the very best. >> I wish you the best, too.
>> Yes. Thank you for coming on.
Bye, guys. >> Bye.
You little piece of
do the same that you always do.
Your moral superiority.
Get that sparkle out of your eye.
>> Put that >> You just put it in. You can't put
a sparkle in my eye and tell me to take it out immediately. >> Wipe
that smile off of your mouth. >> How do you do a little
Well,
>> bother me so bad with your like you are. You're the
doctor. This I'm actually going to call you the doctor.
>> I'm going to call you. You're the
You want to join? You want JSCLK to
>> Yeah. Uh JCLK, I think that you probably you have some
insights.
>> Have anything to hide?
>> Hey, bud.
>> How's it going? >> A little uh emotional. >> Yeah,
you guys were kind of It seemed like seemed like Max in Max basically
insulted Lav early on. I can't even remember what she said and
Lav was just she spent the rest of the conversation getting even
with you. >> Getting even.
>> Getting even a little bit. Yeah. Yeah. just a little
bit setting up my stream.
>> Uh like the whole conversation
>> like what did I say that was getting
>> it was just he was trying to get something done or whatever
and you know >> it's not getting even. It's not getting
even. I just have different I have different thoughts about it.
I I come from a from a from a place of um
I don't know. No, I think I think this is more interesting than
I think uh that I'm like a victim of something. Like I'm more
analytical about it than Max is more emotional about it. Like
I I that's the difference. It's not It's not that like It's not
that I was trying to get him. It's just that I have different
goals of the conversation and what I want to talk about. And
you know, >> I was saying you were trying to get Max after
he kind of pointed out that you were not going the direction
you wanted to go. >> Yeah, but I didn't we weren't we didn't
have to be in cahoots.
That's true. That's true. >> You were You were subverting
my goal. >> You were subverting mine, too.
>> I know. >> So, what Well, I actually I actually
don't know what you guys wanted to achieve, but I kind of wanted
to talk like where where were both of you planning to go there,
Max? Some people in chat kind of thought you were thinking along
the lines of like, I don't want to push you back into this thing
like when people first leave
>> That's interesting. Uh, I wasn't I I mean I don't think
he's going back. I wasn't worried about that.
Um, I just want to
I don't know. It feels like a kind of a public service. I just
I I do think it's a cult and I think people who are watching
who are kind of like I don't know maybe this is weird are are
best served and I think Connor himself are best served by like
I think I think it it preserves the cult to have every single
per like the number of exorbiters
is so large now
and they all hate each other. They're all like, "Well, yeah."
They're like, >> "I know that like it's a cult and they
say everybody who criticizes Destiny is like an evil person,
but everybody who left before me actually is a bad person." And
so, I think just like showing up and being nice to Connor is
a way to kind of implicitly challenge that narrative of like
especially given that he and I said almost identical things and
had and had almost identical experiences of like I'm trying to
be your friend, but like you're being a horrible person and I
have to criticize you or I'm going to be enabling that and then
when I criticize you then now I see now I'm just one of the bad
people. So I was trying to
not like deprogram him
but
>> be his therapist and his uh his doctor. That's what
you're trying to do. >> Sponsor is be his sponsor. >> Yeah.
He was your patient. He was your patient. like everyone's your
patient. Everyone becomes your patient even though you are up
and don't know what's going on either. >> So [laughter]
considering considering you had that goal and you put forethought
into that, do you think it was particularly egregious that lab
was doing the thing you were trying explicitly not to do? >> I
really I didn't
think it through. I should have told I guess I thought that she
was going to I don't know why I thought this.
I thought that she would want to do the same thing. [laughter]
Hearing myself say it, it's just
hilarious.
But >> I thought she would at least let me do it. Famous
last words. >> Lab, could you just lie there and not move?
Could you just lie there and not move for
>> I get it. Yeah.
But didn't work out that way. >> That's [laughter] fair.
That's fair.
>> What are you laughing about?
>> I thought that you I thought we were going to be on
the same page. I thought you were going to thought you going
to let me >> When are we ever
>> I thought you going to let me do my thing and you didn't.
>> You said that you didn't even want to be
>> You're okay. So, you both You're like You're like, "Yeah,
I don't know." And then I'm like, "It's okay. If you're uncomfortable,
you can leave. I'll take the reins basically." And then you But
then somehow you got in there and were like, "I'm going to take
the reins." Which like, "Okay." >> It just didn't feel
safe what you were
>> What do you mean safe?
say a vulnerable person and he's getting dogpiled by a cult.
I mean, it's he's >> it's not that serious, dude. It's
not that serious. All I need to do is log >> It is
It is pretty pretty brutal. It's pretty
>> Oh my god. >> Not anymore. Maybe while we were
Maybe while we were going through it and it was really brutal
because >> Yeah. When it happened to us that was serious,
but now that >> Well, no, he because he [laughter] still
he still had credibility. He still had credibility and there
were still people who were like kind of normal people that were
on his side. Now he only has
>> even just reading like YouTube comments and and tweets
is like
just having so many different usernames
all pariting the same
narrative about you.
Even if there's no like reach to it and it doesn't matter, it's
still really reallyed up like to experience that. And well, we
all know that. I feel like you know that. I think all three of
us know >> I don't know if you guys saw Did you guys see
that he tweeted a picture of Connor's kid? >> Yeah, I did
see that during it.
>> why did he do that? >> Uh, while you guys were
talking >> 15 minutes ago. Yeah. >> Yeah. He's like,
>> what does the tweet say? >> That he like accused
Yeah. He accused he was like the real reason he didn't want me
to talk about this or something is because he was sending me
uh
age play. He was doing age play with me and it was like a picture
of him holding his like baby
>> with like the eyes crossed out. >> Yeah. Um >> cuz
even his his even his audience was
>> Yeah. That thinking his audience was going to be on
board with that is
>> this is what I'm saying. Like he's losing it. He's completely
losing it. He's not there anymore. Like he's got all the room
in the world to lose it and fall and people will try to catch
him. It's a at any point he like wakes up and stops acting like
this. He would be
So he's going for
the person I was with doing age play with sending me pictures
allegedly
was they just because they were sending me pictures doesn't mean
it's age play related to the pictures and so therefore when Connor
does it this proves
I see the I see the logic
Well, that does seem
That does seem like a really
weird thing to do. I How is Connor going to react? I'm surprised
that he would do
Destiny deleted the tweet apparently. And I don't know if Connor
is going to react or not. I Connor might react. Connor is a conservative.
I He could react badly.
>> I mean, it's such a betrayal. like he's obviously sending
him the picture of like
to bond with him as a friend >> or I mean it could be public
too. I have no idea.
I I hope it's not a if it if it was like a DM picture
but it's >> it's fair game to Destiny because he called
them a
>> uh it's a fairly closeup detailed picture. It's not
like it's not I'll just describe it. He's like holding his in
right in front of the camera. It's it's a
objectively up to tweet out in this situation for sure.
>> I'll put the I'll put the text on. I didn't want to
say anything, guys, but the reason Conor's freaking out so much
right now is because
he was the one trying to do age play by sending me pictures of
his
>> it's also just not funny.
>> It's also just like not funny. >> That's like
almost all of his tweets lately. But >> Right. Well, that's
what I'm saying. He's completely losing it. His only audience
remaining are people who are like completely
either hate him and think he's a l cow and are like, "This is
my goat. Like, this is my goat, lol." Or like, you know, people
who are like hyper and like like have caregivers. >> Yeah.
I I think what what I don't see that he he just can't understand
this that like there are people with legitimacy who want to interact
with him because he's got a big audience, right? >> But
like he's consistently drawing their attention to things that
aren't anything to do with his political opinion that look terrible.
Like absolutely terrible for him. And I don't know I don't know
why he doesn't see that.
Like there's something going on there. There's a blindness going
on with him right now where he can't see outside of his cult.
>> Survival mode. >> He's making the worst decisions
>> He's in survival mode right now. He's like he thinks
that he's fighting for his life. Like he'll go into like a 700
viewer stream and like fight for his life. Like he literally
is
he's
spiraling. Like he go like he can just ignore all of it is the
craziest thing. Like he could ignore every single thing and he
doesn't. He's obsessed with it. He's obsessed with himself. He's
spiraling. He's desperate. He's like, he's impulsive. He's emotional.
Like he's completely out of control. He I think that he does
have like genuine BPD.
Like Like I think um Connor Connor was like, "Oh, he's a sociopath."
No, he's not. No, he's not at all. He's absolutely on the other
side of this spectrop. He's not a sociopath. He's like he's obviously
like
he's obviously borderline obviously insecure. a narcissist. It
is what it is. How could he not be? He's been online for a million
years. This is like this it trains you to do that. How could
he not be? He's like he's like this like ugly, you know, pear-shaped
guy with breasts. Suddenly has all this attention online. Like
this is this is all he has. This is literally all he has. He
does not have a life outside of this. He's nobody without destiny.
Nobody. So he's like he's fighting for his life every single
day to keep destiny. I can't imagine. I'd actually I mean, can
you even imagine how brutal that would be?
>> What uh did you guys not get to any questions or topics
that you thought you were going to get to?
>> I'm I mean, I really just thought it'd be interesting
to all of us get in a in a room and see what we talked about.
And I think it was interesting. Um but I did I did ask like about
the Predator thing, like whether or not he was a Predator. and
um he was
like actually just but he's always been that so I wasn't actually
shocked but you know it is what it is and then I wanted to talk
about agency and what agency meant like I really wanted to like
break it down in a way where I was like kind of um you wanted
to be like yeah this you know this is this is happening to you
and we've all been here and you're deprogramming but I wanted
to like kind of shake him awake. I wanted to be like, "Okay,
well, let's follow your thought processes and break them down
one by one. See why you believe that. Why do you believe the
things that you do?" Like, I wanted to rip his mind.
>> yeah. But the whole reason that
>> the whole reason he and any of us were in that situation
is because we couldn't tolerate cognitive dissonance. So, >> at
the exact moment that it's starting to resolve and he's being
dogpiled for it, I feel like just laying on more cognitive dissonance
of being like, "What? idea, but you said this and then you said
this and you think this and now this is happening and what about
this? How do you swear all that and just like seeing if he'll
freak out or >> No, it's not seeing if he'll freak out.
It's seeing if he'll have an epiphany and be like, "Wait, I don't
know why I believe the things that I believe." That's it's a
philosophical discussion of like if you break this down, can
you explain to me with your core of self what you know about
yourself and your value system how this tracks?
I think that the even the way you're saying it now where you're
trying to not sound like you're needling just sounds like needling.
It sounds like you are trying to just
make him explode.
>> Okay. You're sensitive.
I like do I you're I Yeah, I don't think that that would happen
with him.
>> I don't think that his emotions are so volatile that
he would explode if he was >> I think that he would probably
just put walls up. Lock down. Yeah, is what I was going to say.
I was going to say lock down is what I think. He doesn't explode.
He just locks down. >> It's difficult to have a combo.
>> And I wanted I wanted >> That's true. He was extremely
open to
>> I wanted >> I've talked to Connor multiple times.
I've talked to him a billion times. He's very susceptible and
he's very He's very
>> Multiple. No, say billion. That'll do it. No, I want
I wanted to create a safe space and it felt like you
didn't. [laughter] What is safe about any like what is safety?
I this whole safety thing it's a
>> Safety is knowing that you are allowed to say you that
you're wrong about something or you've changed your mind about
something and no one is going to be like I told you so.
>> I'm never I was never going to say I told you so. >> It
feels like you did.
>> No, I was if he came to the same conclusions as me,
I'd be like well that's where that's where I got to after I did
my journey. I this I got to very similar places. That's what
I would have said. It wasn't like an I told you so. It was like,
yeah, I got there, too. Or if he didn't, >> I felt like
>> I'd be like, well, I did not come to that conclusion
myself. We have different values.
>> I felt like the point where you were making it that
you were making about how he basically hasn't had agency anywhere.
That felt like um >> Oh, yeah. >> I told you so.
Like I like I feel like if I went back and watched the VODs and
maybe this isn't true, but I feel like if I went back and watched
VODs of like the whole breakup thing if you ever talked to Connor,
I feel like that's what you'd be telling him is like you don't
have any agency. You're a part of a cult. You don't even know
what's going >> Yeah. You're like your whole life >> you've
been a little lost lamb and DG attracts people like you.
>> That's that's I told you so >> a little bit. >> No.
So, I'm I'm functioning off of I'm functioning off of the idea
that he
>> Well, it came from him saying that he is anti antisocial
behavior, right? That's what he said moments before I tried to
see what his value system was and tried to hold it up.
>> You're reframing that as mindless
>> Not necess
No, I think that you were having a conversation that I was not
having and you thought that I was having a conversation I wasn't
having
because I was not doing that. I was trying to find the peaks
and the cracks of his value
and also like okay if you have your whole life sort of followed
schools of thought like DG or
>> or or all of that then I wonder then I wonder what is
the core of that like what is the what is the core of that what
are what is the through line between all >> you're calling
you're calling his religion and his military >> and Where
is your >> belief system a mindless cult? You're >> no
I'm not. You don't. No. This is why you piss me off. This is
why you piss me off because you think that you read my mind and
you don't. That's not This is why you do that pisses me off.
I don't do that. I was literally going to >> I read your
words. I read your tone. I read your face. I read >> my
tone. Maybe. My tone. Maybe. My tone. Maybe. I'll give you that.
is my tone is I'm I have a really hard time with my tone and
managing my tone. >> You know, your mind is hooked up to
all the stuff you're doing and saying,
>> "No, I'm I'm like a very my tone is something that's
completely different from my brain, I think. And I I do have
to work on that actually." But no, I was literally trying to
come from like his his sense of
values, identity, and then have a more honest conversation from
there. Okay. >> Lack of identity.
>> No, it's not. Nobody has a lack of
>> Yo, you're attacking his lack of >> Nobody has
a lack of identity. I didn't think that he didn't have an identity.
I wanted to see what his core was, what he thought about himself,
and why he had the authority to talk about,
what was moral, why he believed that this was the right choice,
why he like that was a more interesting conversation to me. And
I'll probably still have it with Connor and you'll see that I'm
not trying to do that. >> Well, you know the you know what
the answer is, right? He believes that like commitment and loyalty
are very important values that you should hold. So it's not that
it's mindless. It's that he thinks that even if there are rock
if there's like bumps in the road, you should remain committed
on a path.
>> People need very few bumps in the road to start re-evaluating
changing things. >> Well, I a very bumpy road. >> I
had a feeling that it would come to something like that like
un like maybe at least with this friendship with Steven unconditional
love and then also endurance and resilience. Like that's what
I thought it was going.
Uh maybe, but I didn't have the chance to even have that conversation
because Max wanted to have the conversation about how he's better
than everyone because he he sees the cult for what it
>> Well, I think that the resistance to
my goals itself is kind of a demonstration of what I'm talking
about. So, I was happy. >> I want to you. >> I get
it. Yeah.
both that you want to kill him and what Max is saying. >> No.
And you did, you know, and you did the same and you did the same
thing. >> Oh, yeah. Here we go. Here it comes.
>> Lav, you look very skinny right now, just so you know.
>> Thanks. You did the same thing. you like tried to mindread
me, but it was in a like misogynistic and way where you thought
that I I could not have had anything to add that was like that
was salient or like or
>> um or or good or like >> you like assumed that
the place I was going was like a negative place.
um which was
>> that you do often and it sets the tone because you are
especially with Connor because one you're a man and he's a misogynist
and two it sets the tone for the audience because you're a man
and I'm a woman.
>> And I'm me and you're you. And it it also like you know
you you you don't give me the opportunity to show that like no
I actually know what's going on.
I am asking questions that are pointed for a reason and they're
not going to a bad place because I'm just a person built off
of spite and
evil and and you don't even let me get to the meat of it. You
don't even let me like be
normal now. I'm like typ casted and you keep me
>> as a horrible woman.
>> Yes. It bothers me bad. You've done this separate. You
do this every time we're live.
I think I also what's worse is that I acknowledge it afterward
every >> Yeah, you do. >> You say this every time
and then I'm like, "Yeah, you're right."
>> And then I do it again. >> You're like, I know
you were doing something bad and I'm just like, dude, I'm literally
You didn't even let me get You didn't You didn't let me get literally
at one point I said four words and you shut me out before I could
get there. Like you did not let me >> No, you literally
did not let me finish a sentence before you were like you're
drilling into him and I'm like dude I'm I'm probing him and trying
to have a conversation where like we understand each other.
I think I am trying
to get across my concerns about the cult structure by not even
downplaying but accurately portraying the extreme
lack of agency that I see in its memory.
>> Yeah. And I think >> because we did I know that's
what we're disagreeing about. So then, so where I see somebody
who's basically helplessly a kite in a hurricane, >> but
none of us were.
Not even one of us were. >> That is not the conclusion
that I >> Okay. Well, I think that that's >> that's
not where I'm at. That's not where I ended up. >> Okay.
Well, all all of us all of us have agency and I did not end up
at the same place as you. And I think that maybe taking a little
bit more responsibility for my part is what's I think propelled
me into a different sort of person. In some ways, I've tried
to take a lot out of this situation and been like, you know what,
I had a lesson to learn. I had my own part in it. I have to take
responsibility for my actions inside of it. This is who I'm going
to be moving forward. And I think that that was more helpful
to me than just being like, I'm a victim of this person.
Well, maybe more helpful to you or feel better, but that doesn't
make it true.
>> You want to know what's funny? The first thing I thought
as Lav was explaining that was I was like, I really um I had
to figure out how to stop Max from trying to say that like whatever
piece you have could be elucery. I that was exactly where my
head went. And then
>> you weren't fast enough. >> I was very slow. Yeah,
I was very slow.
>> Okay. I mean, this isn't something that affects me anymore
at all, like at all. So, I think I took the I think I took the
right way out. I I also haven't had any sort of degragation of
any sort of relationship since then. Like, I I've I've been on
the up. I've learned how I've I've learned a lot about myself
intrapersonally and interpersonally.
So, I mean, even taking
>> I was just going to say even if you hadn't, I don't
think that would necessarily mean you were still affected by
it or still like in all of it in some way. Even if you'd been
having a rough time, I think you could easily have moved past
this, right? It's it's good that you're thriving. It's good that
school's going good. You're writing a book. Your marriage is
going well. That's all great. I'm just saying that even if you
weren't, like it wouldn't necessarily mean that you had [__]
up >> Destiny broke me. My career died. my girlfriend left
me and I went bald. >> Other than that, things are going
well. >> Other than that, >> that's not what I'm
saying either. I'm I'm It's not even the fact that my life is
better and like that my, you know, I'm going to school and I
have a husband who I love. It's like it's just like I I g I gained
necessary experience, but I also was only 22 when it happened.
So like [laughter] I was 23 when everything was happening. So
it's like I was a freshly jellied baby into the world. And I
I in a lot of ways I got to move on um in a big way which you
know and I talked to you about this I think like months ago where
I was like in some ways like you did not get that you had this
like burgeoning career that you had cultivated that you had cultivated
and then you sort of had it like ripped from you and burned to
the ground. So, we're coming from maybe I was just harmed less
than you were.
And I and honestly, I also got some really good licks in. Like,
if you would have gotten a couple of licks in, maybe you would
have felt different, but I got a lot of really good licks in.
So,
I don't know. All you know, it's to me it was just war and I
won.
That's how I feel. >> Okay. I don't know. So,
the amount of sensitivity I was showing to Connor
threatens your narrative that you won.
>> is that what you're trying to say?
>> Your what? Me me me me me me me me me me me me me me
me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me me
me me me me me me me me being really sensitive to Connor threat
by implication threatens your narrative that that you won or
that it was war and I'm acting him I'm acting like he's >> No,
I think I think it
>> I think it threatens my agency period.
>> And also what I think is one of my values
which is um introspection
over being right or being a victim.
Like it was more valuable to me to introspect about that situation
than to um
than to tell everyone that I was a victim of someone. >> But
that's like guided introspection that has to lead to a conclusion
that you're not a victim. >> No, I still think that I'm
I still think that I was a victim. Like in >> this is what
I'm saying. This is where it's fuzzy. It's like are the are we
are are we victims? Are we mentally ill? Do we have agency?
Did we win? Was it just a fight? Did we get good listen? Do we
>> both? First of all, both and all things can be true
depending on how you look at them. And that's true about everything
in the world. >> That Yeah, but that depending on how you
look at it, I think is part of the
cult. That's part of the >> Max. No, that's about life.
You're But this is your own is that you're just uncomfortable
with life and its
This is this is a deeper thing. >> I'm bald. Don't tell
me about reality. >> He's bald and he's torturing people
out of hair.
I see the same thing. I don't know if you've ever watched any
of um like Pisco talk, but Pisco has gotten into some tussles
with DG recently and people act like they can't understand him.
And to me, it's like I'll literally walk with him while he's
talking and I'll pause and I'll explain the exact direction he's
going, what argument he's about to make. And it's like it's so
easy to understand.
And then I feel the same way for Max. I know where he's going,
what he's trying to say, what he's trying to get to, and why
the thing he's saying is actually important. But I don't think
Live's doing that from a cult perspective. I think Live's doing
that from a She's from interrupting her
>> I feel the same way. I Me and Max have no problem talking
oneon-one. We understand each other. I know what he's going to
say. He knows what I'm going to say. When you're talking to someone
like Connor who needs to be like like a dog, like told exactly
the point so he doesn't meander like he was, like he literally
continued to. That's the problem.
M >> at least to the point >> maybe Connor Connor
has a problem of he needs to use anecdotes. He's like thought
of one way to to make his point. >> So he's always going
to use that point and he's going to use like an anecdote that
goes with that point and that could like sometimes make a point
in 20 words, but he will take like 10 minutes. >> It feels
like a it does feel like a defensive measure when he does it.
>> Uh I've seen it used that way. Yes, I've seen it used
that way.
>> I agree that Pisco is a very organized speaker. Yeah,
I just wasn't sure if you I I've been following like quite a
bit of that podcast because Pisco and Hutch have like a podcast
with a couple other people and I I listen to it a decent amount
and >> it's interesting how that podcast has sort of been
subsumed into some DG adjacent drama as well. Feels like the
the tentacles are far reaching
>> Yeah.
So you >> crazy made me
in your head.
>> It's not. [laughter] It's good one though. You're just
imagining it. >> Good one. [clears throat] Right. That's
a really good one.
>> I hope that you realize what you just did in the self
and I hope you have
>> but it I fear that you actually did that on accident.
>> Wait, no. Max was definitely making a joke. Come on.
>> No, I fear I fear that it actually >> Did you
see him look in the camera when he said it? >> After after
all these years, you don't trust me just a little bit.
if I would trust you more if you if you held me in high regard
publicly.
>> I Oh, that's
that's tough. You know that sometimes. Okay. I watched this conversation.
There were times where I think if Max wasn't on camera, I feel
like he would have gotten up and like punched a wall. I think
him not like getting mad at you at all was sort of because he
holds you in high regard. He doesn't want to >> He did
get mad at me, but he was No, he did get mad at me, but it was
like passive aggression
>> and it was on his face. and he was saying things that
were undermining in a way that was like whatever. It's I mean
I'm not going to do this publicly because I already know what
I'm setting myself up for when I'm advocating for myself in public.
So >> I agree with you. I agree with you. >> We're
both going back and forth and doing it. I I had the impression
that you did it first, but it doesn't make it okay when Max does
it back.
>> I think I undermined you.
I think I was
and I think I
I think I overreacted
to my sensitivity
to Connor and I think I threw you under the bus and made you
look like a crazy attempted to make you look like a crazy one.
If we go back the points that I made that were uninterrupted
by you,
maybe I got maybe I got one and a half out before you said that
before you stopped me by saying it was evil and that it was bad
and that it was off the and if it was off the mark.
>> I think that it was evil. >> No, I don't think
it was evil. I think it was just
kicking a guy while he's down. And and I understand he's also
kicking you while
while he's down. You made that. >> I don't think I did.
[laughter] I think he's while he's down and you're like kind
of kicking him back. >> Conor and I are friendly. I was
not trying to do that. I was not trying to do that at all and
I wasn't going to. And I think you'll see that in our
in my one-on-one conversation with him. I think that you'll see
exactly what I was trying to do and it wasn't >> the I
think he was in a vulnerable position and he was being and I
think that that puts you in a bad spot where you have to enable
it by not reacting or you have to fight back and then you look
and I think I contributed to that by trying to protect >> the
way that I fight back is >> just being normal and not and
not falling into the trap. >> You were I think you were
needling him.
>> No, I wasn't.
No, I wasn't.
But I do think I overreacted and did do the thing that you're
accusing me of doing. It's in both of our heads. And since it's
in my head, that makes it real. So
>> yeah, cuz you're >> making it up. >> I hate
you. You drag me through the town square calling me a victim.
And then when I and then when I then I when I try to rise above
and
you're keeping me at you're keeping me at 22year-old Lavloon
online. That's where you're keeping me. Is that more comfortable
for you?
For me, for me to be the victim and for you to be the brain,
for me for me to just be your unruly friend who just says the
crazy thing and actually not have any insight. Does that make
you feel good? For you to be the insightful one, Max? Does that
make you feel good?
I bet it does.
I bet it does. >> I don't know about you guys, but sometimes
I sometimes I'm just sitting there and I open my mouth and
a lie just sort of like rolls out. I actually don't know the
precise quote.
>> And here we go. Huh? And here we [laughter] go.
>> I'm laughing. I'm laughing because I don't see you that
way. Okay. [laughter] You know that I don't see you that way,
>> You do to some extent. That's why you brought it up.
>> I think it's a stuck here. And I'm stuck >> All
clip. >> No matter how good I behave. Huh? >> Time
clip. >> No matter how good I behave, I'm stuck >> I
mean, let's not let's not be unreasonable and act like you behave
well. most of the time on the internet.
>> how about when was the last time I badly >> Definitely
outing Ice Boseidon as a but also or at least in that world,
but I'm sure there's been a time since then. >> I don't
think that that's even really badly behaved. But >> but
honestly, it's like I don't see you that way. So, not as the,
you know, live, laugh, lie person, >> I'm stuck here. >> The
jokes the jokes are funny. >> That's what it is. >> You
can you can own the jokes. I think I think you're especially
because you got all those licks in. You can definitely own the
jokes,
>> you know, and now I'm now we're in the place where the
conversation becomes about me and I can't say anything about
myself anymore. So, >> do you want [laughter] do you want
me where where should I move it to? Do you want to go back to
I would go back to where Matt want to talk through like the things
you would like. >> I'd like to resp I'd like to respond
to
>> Okay, go. >> If that's okay. Okay. I
think
that part of my trauma from my DGG experience is
feeling hyper responsible
in a way I already did but it was made
uh specifically for you and around you and other ex other defectors.
And I do think that
that
protectionist, controlling, patriarchal,
paternal instinct
is all the things that you're saying it is. Yes. Yes. I am >> You
You made me You stuck me You stuck me in my position.
>> I'm here forever. >> And I can't And I can't get
out of it. And and this and the second I say I've overgrown it
or I've >> You can't grow. You can't leave. No. Yes. You
I can't move on or heal. >> You are the devouring mother.
>> But you'll be safe. >> You are the devouring mother.
But that's not even what's making me safe because part of what
these people want to kill me for and what they're like, you know,
their criticisms of me are all the things where you keep me.
All the all the places you keep me. I can't be insightful. I
can't be intelligent. all I I mean I ask a couple probing questions
and I can't I can't even get there. You you've made up your mind
that it's gonna be some it's gonna go somewhere that you know
is nefarious.
>> Hold on. That actually is like a good point that I don't
know. I don't think you were here. I think you walked away. But
I asked Max like he basically said that he thought about this
beforehand and he wanted to treat thor gently. And I think if
you guys had coordinated a little bit more beforehand, you wouldn't
have run into that exact >> No, he does this every time.
He does this every time no matter what.
Would have been a different thing then.
>> I'm in these I'm in these chains. He has me shackled.
He won't let me leave my bedroom. [laughter] He's not letting
me have a phone. >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait. So, hold on. Now, we have to unpack that. Cuz
you you felt like I was trying to cast you a certain way when
I made the joke. Were you trying to cast Max a certain way when
you made that joke? >> No, I Well, I don't believe that
about him at I thought it was just a really funny thing to say.
I like I have no I don't believe that even a little bit. >> That's
what I said. That's what I said. >> No, but it it's different
coming from you because you weaponized that against me for like
over a year and you did believe it and probably still do to some
extent. Whereas like I don't I've never believed that about Max
ever. That's why it's like completely a joke when I say
>> But do you believe it metaphorically? >> I [laughter]
don't like that you >> I hope she believes it metaphorically
cuz she did. I don't think that you treat I don't think that
you treated Shaylen the way that you've treated me. >> Lab
is the real Shayen. That's
>> No, no, no, no, no. It's a completely different relationship.
Completely different. It's like it really is like it really is
the devouring mother. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Yes. I really
do have like the Jordan Peterson devouring mother. And yet, you
know, this conversation could have gone really well for me. People
would have been like, People could have been like,
>> Leah's like not the same person."
>> I She's actually She's actually like, she's actually
grown up a lot. >> Well, hold on. >> You couldn't
let me have that. Huh? >> That hold on. That could be true.
Do you think you're ever going to get that in these communities
having any conversation in these communities? Like even adjacent
to them. >> Well, even in I would like for myself to feel
it in the conversation.
>> Okay, that's >> And he wouldn't even let me have
that.
>> you did hurt my feelings though. You will be hearing
from me. >> Okay, see you.
streaming doesn't really bring out the best in me.
>> Probably not anybody.
Yeah. No, it doesn't. >> Might bring out the worst in me.
>> I have yet to meet the person that it doesn't bring
the worst out in
this is uh the way it is.
>> I don't know. It's I think um there's something to be
said for covering stuff where the people don't really know about
you all that much and you just kind of around and have fun.
I do think that once you're
It feels specifically like the um the close relationships make
the content better between like a lot of the creators, but it
also makes it like a lot more real. Like I think people go through
genuine mental like anguish over stuff like this and
it's um
>> it gets quite difficult to process. Also, just the more
you stream with people, the closer you get to them. >> Yep.
And then if you Well, for me, I have an audience that likes like
dramatic content, too. So, obviously, they're going to hope that
they can egg on any fight that could be possible.
>> Which adds like the element that is a little difficult
to deal with. >> She's right though. These are my worst
qualities, tendencies >> that you
feel like you need to control the conversation and be a good
person and be the smartest person who's doing everything correct.
>> Yeah. and make specifically by making women look bad
so I can protect the egos of men.
>> She's not the only person to that pointed this out to
me. Shayen Shaylen said this to me quite a few times.
It gets difficult because there are times where that argument
that that could be true and it could be happening like at the
exact same time as them using that argument to win because they
know they're in the wrong. Like do you know what I mean? Like
that >> I I I don't think function with >> I Yeah.
Yeah. I don't think that what I said was not true, but I do think
the way I did it
was maneuvering in the exact way that she is saying it was. So,
I'm not saying like, oh, I don't think she was needling Connor
or I think she was being super nice to him. I don't I don't but
I also think that I don't know
kind of I kind of >> like the way you pointed out the way
you're like confident about it and undermining basically puts
her in a certain role in the conversation that prevents her from
having success in the
>> Yes. And it makes it so that anything she would do to
get out of that role is just interpreted as her being like >> further
cementing her in that role. Yeah. Yeah. >> It's a Yeah.
It's like a trap. >> Yeah. I've had that criticism as well.
So just the I I think that pretty much that exact criticism.
So >> yes, I think I've seen that happen >> Yep.
Yeah. And it's like it like I said, I'm I'm not quite as intentful
as you are in conversations, so I'm sure I do it in a malicious
way or in a self-s serving way far more often
or at least at least as often. Yeah. Do you have uh you have
any other topics you wanted to talk about or
>> No. it.
>> that's fair.
>> Do you?
>> No. Okay.
Um I'm probably going to disconnect then and just say goodbye
to everybody and then I don't know. Don't be a stranger. I think
I think you might be in the Discord. I'm pretty sure you're in
the Discord. >> I am. >> You ever ever want to hop
on? I know you don't necessarily like streaming, but >> you
know, you ever want to hop on? >> Welcome to. >> Thank
you.
I'm sure we'll talk sooner or later.
>> Yeah, for sure. All right, have a good >> You,
too. >> We'll see you around. See you. Bye.